- I hear you travel around in an RV,
which I love.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- We have an RV.
We have a Cyclone,
my husband and I.
- Really?
Really?
- Yes! It's fun, yeah.
- Years ago, I bought
one and my niece said,
"Well, I guess it's the
boomer thing to do".
You know? Which was like--
(Kelly laughs)
But, what I loved about it,
is we traveled all over the
United States, you know?
Cracker Barrel!
- I love Cracker Barrel.
- We would go to cracker barrels
and what I loved about it,
is I could just be real, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- People were at times complimentary,
but there's no filter and we can just,
you know, they weren't impressed.
- [Kelly] I love that!
- I know.
I remember being in Idaho,
and there was a Native American guy
and he came over to the table
and he had this beautiful,
very simple turquoise necklace
and I commented on it and he took it off
and put it on my neck.
And--
- Good thing you didn't
compliment his pants.
(all laugh)
Just, wow!
I'm just saying.
I see where this is
going and I'm like whoa!
Just putting it on you!
- I'm taking this, and then I'm going.
Okay, no, but cool thing about it was,
he explained that that's
what Indian giving means.
- Oh, the real meaning?
- The real meaning of
it because we often say,
"You're an Indian giver"
and that's not it.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I always
find that very offensive.
- I know.
If you compliment, you
have to give it to them,
and that's Indian giving.
- Oh, my gosh!
I compliment people all the time.
I would have so many things.
(audience laughing)
I love complimenting people
because you meet people,
especially like fans and stuff and--
- Well, I loved your earrings.
- Exactly, here you go.
(all laughing)
But, do you still use the RV?
- No, it's in storage.
I used it on the Warner Brother's lot,
but the driver and I broke up.
- Oh, no! Oh, no!
(both laughing)
- You are making me cry with laughter.
I swear to god.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, my gosh! That's my eye that waters.
We have so much in common.
- [Kathy] I know!
(all laughing)
♪ Sisters ♪
- I know that song!
That's my favorite!
Oh, I love you, okay.